THIN LEAGUE IN GOALS AGAINST
AVERAG 15,
LINDHOLM POINT. TALL.
>> John: BACK-TO-BAC
>> John: DUCKS ONE FOR MIKE TO
BACK ON N  THAT PUCK AND IMMEDIY
TRY TO HEADMANNED IT AS HE HAD
THE CALGARY
NETMINDER.
>> John: TREVOR ZEGRAS, 12
THE TRAILER A BACKLUND.
T RIGHT
ON.
GIBSON SAVES TO THE CORNER. JohK
WITH RAKELL DOWN LOW.
LOUIS TRIES T
MILANO!
SPEECH OF THE OTHER BIG FACTOR
IS RICKARD RAKELL, STATIONARY AE
GAME'S FIRST GOAL. RIGHT BY FOUS
IT DOWN LOW.
IT'S THAT LITTLE CHOP BY MONAHAN
ACROSS TO COLEMAN THAT REALLY,
THE REASON FOR THIS PUCK BEING
IN.ON THE WALL.
ALL OF HER KYLINGTON OF THE
MIDDLE OF
COUNTER FROM THE BLUE LINE IN.
THERE IS THAT PUCK AWAY FROM STD
MONAHAN ACROSS THE LINE. DEFENS.
MONAHANSDALE.
IN FULL FLIGHT.
IT HITS A THE NEUTRAL
ZONE.
GAME AFTER
GAME. IT HAD TO.
RAKE IT.
THIS ONE LOOKS PRETTY DARN
GAME.
VINNI THE
BLUE
DRAW TO BE TAKEN BY ELIAS
LINDHOLM.
HE IS OUT WITH GAUDREAU AND
TANEV PLAY THE DUCKS BACK FOR ET
HAMPUS DROPS IT OFFEM UP HIGH,
PICKS ON TOP CORNER.
>> Joh
KEVIN SHATTENKIRK IS A NUMBER
TWO O n: EVERYONE'S FAVORITE
MATTHEW TKACHUK AND WIN IT FOR
THE FLAMES.
THE DUCKS NEED A SAFE ROOM
GIBSON.
TKACHUK WITH SP